let's go
over the last two years fitness
sensation peloton has been on a wild
ride
even before the pandemic the
subscriber-based company had amassed a
cult following
and at the height of the pandemic shares
reached all-time highs no one is getting
left behind pelotonis for anyone who
wants it but then almost suddenly the
world and peloton's luck shifted gyms
and offices began reopening as lockdown
restrictions were lifted and over a
single year the company lost nearly all
of its pandemic stock market gains
here's how peloton the once high-flying
fitness craze spun out losing billions
of dollars in market share in the
process
peloton launched a decade ago as a
stationary bike company that had big
aspirations for democratizing the
fitness world
peloton had this vision pre-pandemic
even that everyone who had broadband
internet would want a peloton and could
afford a peloton laura foreman covers
technology for the herd on the street
column at the wall street journal
she says that the company's subscribers
were primarily wealthy consumers with
the means to invest in high-end exercise
equipment with a monthly subscription
fee this is a company that wanted to be
accessible but gained a cult following
because it was the opposite of that it
was aspirational and it really became
this whole lifestyle that's one reason
and then the second reason is just
people were obsessed with the content
but the company knew that to continue to
grow it needed to expand its user base
and in early 2020 as the world shut down
demand for home exercise equipment
surged people weren't traveling they
weren't going outside so maybe they had
some of that budget that they could sort
of allocate to fitness pelton come on
let's get this workout started and with
the surge in demand the fitness company
became a big success its market value
grew considerably reaching almost 50
billion dollars in early 2021 up from
just seven billion dollars two years
prior over a single year the company
gained almost a million new subscribers
but even in the midst of its success
during the pandemic peloton was already
facing issues by late 2020 as demand for
its products soared the company was
racing to fill orders but it was
struggling to keep up complaints from
customers about delays and missed
deliveries mounted and peloton's share
price began to plunge they invested a
ton in sustaining this monster growth
that was never going to be sustainable
and then in march 2021 a fatal incident
occurred involving peloton's high-end
treadmill tragic peloton accident that
resulted in the death of a child the
company is issuing new warnings to
owners in the wake of the accident the
incident pushed peloton to recall its
treadmills and this move was costly
peloton estimated that recalling and
halting sales of its treadmills would
cost the company around 165 million
dollars over a single quarter in 2021 it
really through cold water on the notion
that peloton could continue to grow
maybe they were growing too quickly or
they weren't really putting as much
thought into every product trouble for
the company continued into the summer of
2021. as vaccines became more widely
available and gyms began reopening the
company faced mounting challenges when
the world opened up and all the people
who could afford a peloton already had
one you saw demand start to decline in
the attempt to appeal to a broader
audience peloton slashed prices but as
demand continued to fall the move ended
up hurting the company's bottom line by
the end of the year peloton's stock had
plummeted losing more than
three-quarters of its value from its
december 2020 high which erased most of
its pandemic era gains the company's
market value had dropped about 85
percent then in early 2022 the company
changed its price decision and added
hundreds of dollars in fees to its bike
and treadmill a move that came as the
company grappled with waning demand
and for some investors the situation
looked dire around the same time news
broke that peloton was temporarily
halting production of its connected
fitness products amid a company-wide
hiring freeze peloton the shares
reopened after being halted twice
they're now down more than 20 percent
just weeks later under pressure from an
activist investor the company announced
it would be replacing its ceo and
cutting 2 800 jobs about 20 percent of
its workforce in an effort to get back
on track the changes announced are
exactly the types of things that
investors and analysts want to be seeing
it's you know a new a new manager um a
new uh cost structure foreman says it's
no coincidence that the new ceo barry
mccarthy was the cfo of netflix and
spotify both lower price
subscription-based companies some think
barry's gonna come in and
completely change the company from a
company that was aspirational to a
company that truly is accessible with
really
lower price subscription
models
others think there's really no hope for
the company and it just needs to get
sold but one thing is for certain the
road ahead for peloton is a steep climb
[Music]
you